and welcome to episode number 33 of the
weekly Google cloud platform podcast I
am Francisco and I'm here with my
colleague mark Mendel hey Mark
hey Francis how you doing very good and
you very well I feel like I haven't seen
you for a long time yeah I think so long
yeah
so today we're gonna be talking with
someone that I met during doing a
conference in Budapest in Kraft Kampf
yeah and I saw him wearing a Travis CI
sticker on his back and I thought that
it was because his name was Travis and
it turns out that he was the CEO of
Travis Matias Matias Mayer oh no one
important yeah no one important so he
was visiting San Francisco so we decided
to invite him in exchange of some free
food at Google and in exchange he
allowed us to interview him he's gonna
be talking about all the cool things
they do at Travis CI was continuous
integration continuous deployment and
how they run on Google cloud platform
yeah really really fun thing love
talking about testing love talking about
that side of software development so
super interesting conversation yep and
after that once we finish with that
interview we'll have a question of the
week that is about a topic that I think
we've covered before that can really
save you time we've covered once or
twice so yeah we're gonna be talking
about kubernetes and what do you do when
you have very specific things that you
want to know but before that we're gonna
go with a cool thing of the week and it
is very very cool thing of the week if
you ask me
well yeah you you've had a chance to
play with this so when you tell us about
what you've been up to it is something
that it is very cool and actually wrote
a blog post it's so basically you know
this thing github where people put code
I have heard of it yes so we got all the
code which is a couple terabytes of code
from github and we dumped it on to
bigquery okay and then now you can do
queries on that so it's like all the
code all the commits everything all the
code or the come
I think all the comments have older
branches but it is it is a crazy amount
of got it
and so yeah I wrote a blog post because
basically I was like oh what can I do
with this so I wrote a blog for things
like okay what is the most common file
name for go files and what is the most
common package name what is the most
common and what one that it was actually
kind of complicated is what is the most
important package and go all across
github and it is really fun because
basically you can just write some sequel
and you need to know so you go a little
bit like I had some had some personal
issues with it but it was definitely
worth it so and there's actually way
more different articles about it so
basically we have will link to the blog
post a road but there's also one other
blog post that talks about analysis for
all the languages all the things and
it's a public data set so anyone can
play with it right it is public you can
go and play with it and and try to find
cool things that you could do best part
of it you can also run JavaScript or
bigquery with UDF user-defined functions
yeah which means that you can actually
do JavaScript analysis of the content of
the files you can start doing really
cool stuff in there
interesting so how many times did you
find in the codebase where it says if
error is not equal nil rather not commit
okay great so I think that is time to go
talk with our Matias sounds good little
chat so we're here with Matias Meier hi
Matias all right and you're the CEO of
Travis CI that's right yeah that is
awesome thank you so much for coming it
is awesome to have a guest like you
so before we start talking about Travis
CI and all the things that you do and
everything why don't you tell us a
little bit about yourself okay my name
is Matthias Mayer I'm from Berlin in
Germany which is where a big part of our
company is I'm the CEO of Travis CI
which is a hosted continues integration
platform we have pretty strong roots in
open source with I think we have a
couple of hundred thousand projects
running on Travis CI particular open
source projects and
yeah cool well a couple hundred thousand
like nothing you know that's cool so
what is it day in the life of Matthias
look like at Travis oh that's a that's
an interesting one so a couple of years
ago that they look like there's alerts
coming in and I would respond to them
these days it's that was a couple of
years ago when our team was still very
small at this point our team is closer
to forty people so it's more like
figuring out what the future looks like
what is the future of CI look like which
is what's the future of continuous
delivery look like and how does it
impact our product and you know what can
we what other things can we do for open
source and we also have strong roots in
a you know increasing diversity in
software development and open source as
well and it's you know a good mix of
these things like lots of daily daily
business and operations in the company
lots of talking to people lots of
talking to customers mmm nice so you
mentioned that Travis CI the CI stands
for continuous integration why don't you
tell us it a bit about what is
continuous integration for people that
don't know what it is okay so a lot of
this goes back to extreme programming
where two of the practices were you
build every commit like every what
everything you check in is going to be
tested and the other practice is I
forgot what the other practice was um
anyway I'm gonna focus on that one
because that's that's the best one so
continuous integration focuses around
the idea that every change you make to
the codebase is you know run in an
isolated environment you you know you
test those changes and you build compile
something and then you run a test suite
that hopefully exists for this project
to make sure that the change that you're
made still works in the in the bigger
picture of the of the test suite cool
so I'm assuming that with that basically
what you're trying to do is to try to
get a bill that always builds and as
soon as someone messes it up you just
know so you know yes you want to be
notified when something happens I think
the definition of continues integrating
actually goes a lot goes a lot further
than that like depending on who you ask
it is it is also a development practice
it's
practice of continuously integrating
your code into into trunk there's a very
controversial thing still to make sure
that no changes that you make a live off
the main the the main trunk for longer
than a day it was extreme programming
had this practice of at the end of the
day if you're not done with your change
you delete the code Wow it's very
controversial still at this point this
is like we're now I don't know how many
years post extreme programming 15 20
years yeah like that yeah yeah I was
thinking extreme programming that is
what stands for on Windows XP it was it
was yeah it was xp for short but I'm not
sure they yeah yeah I think it goes back
a lot further that no it was a set of
practices like good development noctis's
one of them that we also try to live in
the company was is to to go home tired
but not exhausted you know like the good
balance in encoding you know you don't
want to you know spend 12 hours a day
working on code you want to you know
give it your best give it your best like
say at a normal pace for eight hours a
day say the end of the day the code is
hopefully checked in yeah and you just
go home then all the live outside of
work which is definitely one of my
favorite extremely excellent all right
so we talked about continuous
integration how does Travis CI enable
you to do continuous integration so one
of the things we pride ourselves in is
our easy integration with github as I
mentioned before we have I don't know
how many hundred thousand open source
projects somewhere around three hundred
fifty thousand at this point running on
Travis CI and it's the it's just really
easy to set up you sign up with your
github account we synchronize all of
your repositories from github and you
just activate one add a file to your
code repo which is a built definition
you can customize built steps we have a
couple of sensible defaults for you know
common languages but you can customize
the bill to your liking so as soon as
you enable it you can just start
checking code and we'll start building
it so it's just really really easy to
get started usually just takes minutes
so basically I can sit down take my
open-source card I don't
to worry about building infrastructure
around doing my continuous integration I
can just work on my project check it in
tune as I check it in it runs all my
tests through the I guess it's a Travis
yeah mole or something yes the file is
called a Travis llamo and it's part of
your code repo so it's the you know we
give developers the power to have full
control over their build which is
definitely something people appreciate
and also the the you know the build
definition itself is part of the code
you know its version in the same way and
you can trace any changes that you make
it can trace you to get trace through
the entire history alright so cool and
then so as I'm building it will notify
me if something breaks yes um I assume
then also if I get like a pull request
or something like that for my code does
that also run so I can see whether it
should be merged in case something
happened bad or anything like that yeah
that's definitely one of the one of the
reasons why Travis CI exists especially
in open source there was a time when you
you got a pull request through your
repository I think early on it was in
github terms it was a the for queue or
before that you just gotta patch my
email I remember old old back in the day
and you would merge it and then you
committed to you know your trunk branch
you would hopefully have a CI running
and only then would you know if it's
actually working yeah that patch is
working so you would either be happy
because the patch is working or you
would scream in agony because now you
have this patch to maintain and make
sure that you break you fix a bill that
someone else broke and that is one of
the core problems that Travis tried to
solve we now have we have a native
integration with pour request is like if
there's a project that's running that's
using Travis CI and someone sends a poor
request to it we we take the merge the
merged between the branch at send to and
the the the downstream changes and test
that part so we we focus really on the
integration between all of them so it's
like you know a different kind of
continuous integration if you will and
make sure that you know the change works
together with wherever the the trunk
branches at the moment cool and I think
that that is free if you are writing
open-source yeah if you're if you're
running open source project the usage is
completely free on Travis CI nice what
if you're not running open source what
if you have a private repo or something
like that if you
or private repos we have a hosted
platform for that which is a paid
platform cool but you still support it
even if the code is not prior yeah it's
nice very cool
now that sounds really good it means
also like if you're following that
internal pull request model you want to
do code reviews internally when you're
building stuff then you know it's all
the same it's a fairly common model now
even in companies to work like it's you
know github flows basically the you know
a good name for it getup has a good
documentation of this you know you start
working on a future branch you start
opening a pull request you iterate
around the pour request and drivers can
as soon as a pull request is updated we
automatically rerun the build github
tracks
you know the merge between the
downstream branch at the upstream branch
for us so we can just we can just take
that commit and test it all the time
whenever the pour request is updated so
it's once you actually want to merge it
you're at the point where you can be
certain that it's gonna work against the
against the master branch or whatever
branch is you open the port request
against yeah and I know that nowadays
I'm not able to work without Travis CI
or something similar to that because it
is very painful when you change
something you're like oh yeah I totally
did not break the build and it's like I
did so yeah it is very good to see it
before you do anything you know
specially full requests from people that
you might trust and often I was like oh
actually that is wrong also we've been
using it internally in one of the
projects I'm working on where we done
only run tests but also we run things
like styling and style checks and stuff
like that like yeah you just misspell
something on a comment that will break
the bill interesting here people have
built interesting things about this
there's like there's a conference that's
currently planning if I just saw this
yesterday who have a site that they're
running on Travis the static page but
part of that page is a JavaScript file
which runs on nodejs and it calculates
their budget so it's gonna fail the
build if the budget is negative oh nice
and you know and if the budget is still
if it's still positive in the green it's
just gonna it's gonna succeed the build
so people have build interesting things
on around Travis yeah that is very cool
and so whenever you send a poor request
it says well we need to make this budget
adjustments right no no we don't
nice so talking about microservices and
stuff like that like very often
continuous integration comes up but also
there's another thing that comes up very
often which is continuous delivery what
are the relationship between both so it
depends on who you ask I would say
continuous delivery is usually
associated with complex pipelines like
you know your build runs through stages
you know you make a commit you start say
running unit tests and then you have
maybe a QA QA stage that is manually
driven and then you have a deployment
stage which eventually gets your code
either staging or the production and for
me this there's the difference between
CI and CDs so continuous integration
continuous delivery is really really
it's rather simple
CI basically means you you test every
commit you know you make sure that any
change that you make still works or can
you know as could be made could be
pushed into production and the
continuous delivery beyond all these
pipelines and you know the just or the
idea of shipping continuous delivery is
to me more simply the idea that you
could ship your code any time okay like
the code that you check in could be
deployed at any moment
so using adjust your mental model of how
you work around the code accordingly
yeah so even if you've just like pushed
to staging for QA but then that's I mean
that's basically the same thing right as
long as you've got a push-button
solution yeah that you're just like oh
that's good to go now cool so I'd like
to talk now a little bit about Travis
itself and how Travis works so the first
question is does Travis use continuous
integration internally yes good CI uses
Travis CI for a lot of things yeah
inception yeah I mean it's a that's the
first litmus test for any kind of
infrastructure solution can it you know
can it maintain itself yeah and it's
been I mean it was originally built as a
single not as a multi-tenant solution it
was originally built as something one of
our co-founders wanted to run on you
know you didn't want to run Jenkins you
wanted to have something that runs on
Heroku and so he started adding a couple
of nice features like life built lock
streaming and other stuff and based
around that like the
in the early Travis coat was you know
even six years ago the early Travis coat
was running on itself nice and it still
lives like we're avid users and we also
have a project which is which is a
canary built system which continuously
runs built on Travis to check the entire
system is a fairly active project at
this point yep
cool and what about continuous
deployment are containers delivery sorry
we deploy or our general approaches that
people work on feature branches they we
try to make them you know short lift
some live longer but the idea is still
that tree you know trunk or master and
get this deploy should be deployable
anytime it's still one of the goals and
it you know there's a good chance it's
going to be deployed any time we don't
we don't yet count deploys per day it's
a fairly popular metric at this point
but we're generally we're very flexible
about people deploy and it's like we try
to keep the master branch clean cool so
I guess the big question is you here on
the Google cloud platform podcast do you
run on Google cloud platform yes a part
of our infrastructure runs on Google
compute engine and that part also uses
Google Cloud Storage nice too
specifically to run to use caches like
we we have the system where well most
projects use a certain set of
dependencies like it's true for any kind
of language any kind of language has you
know some package management tool and
the installation depending on the
language can either be a matter of
seconds or of minutes and so we have
this built-in caching that where you can
you know specify a directory or if say
bundle integrations native or NPM
integration as well where we take the
entire set of dependencies and you know
tar it up simply and upload it to Google
compute store cloud storage in this case
and so in the next build it's just going
to be pulled down and extracted and you
know if it's a reasonably good package
management system it's just going to
detect there's always already something
there yeah so it's just going to check
for any changes and install those and it
speeds up builds significantly cool so
when you say that you're running on
Google compute engine does that mean
that for
every bill task that you spawned you
spent a new compute engine instance or
how does that work
yeah when whenever we like for builds
that run on that platform whenever we
get a commit notification from github
you know we go through the process of
creating the build and scheduling it and
once we start executing it every bill
runs in a clean environment that was one
of the early differentiators of Travis
CI that you get a vanilla environment
it's going to be it's going to be
restarted from scratch for every node
and you can rely on that so on Google
compute engine we we start up a new a
new instance for every build and one of
the things that we found there was like
we get fairly stable boot times on
Google compute engine which like which
make it a lot more reliable and that was
one reason why we chose it in the end
cool yeah so have you been considered
doing some things like different like
instead of running one new VM per build
test running one new container or
something like that yes we another part
of our infrastructure does exactly that
how come that part actually uses docker
unto to create the build environment and
that's just super fast like I just
looked up the the stats for how long it
takes to boot up a docker container for
us and I think the the 95th percentile
of that is 3.3 seconds for so this is
when when do you when you look at Travis
while you're committing something you
pretty much see the build start
instantly nice it's like it goes through
the system within a second or something
like that the docker containers just
booted up and it starts running almost
instantly and that part we're still
playing around with that there is
there's still something missing on
Google compute engine that keeps us from
running that part on there but
technically it could run anywhere nice
that's pretty cool so what curious about
how you're controlling those compute
engine instances I know we have a series
of api's but like what's the what's the
life cycle of that kind of look like so
we we have we start you know we hit the
API pretty hard I'm afraid I'm sorry
about that
so we we for every build we send an API
request to create an instance and we
started we keep pulling the API for the
status of that virtual server
and once it's ready you know we the
entire build is executed three and SSH
connection so once it's ready we SSH in
we compile the build script which is you
know uploaded and run on the virtual
server cool it's pretty much it when
it's you know at the end of the tests
just you know terminated and it's done
yeah we're finished so I was wondering
also regarding containers since you're
starting a new one every single time
have you considered doing things like
kubernetes or container engine or
something like that what do you think
about those uh we've thought about it we
just haven't gotten around to this all
right
it's definitely something we have in the
back of our mind to play around with
that a little bit we just like mean
basically we have our own scheduling and
maybe you know this ways to optimize
that but we we haven't gotten to run to
it it's definitely something we have on
the radar cool is that scheduling open
source by any chance
most of Travis CI is open source and I
think that part in particular is yes
everything about that is open source
like the entire build execution part and
our scheduler which is really really
simple sounds sounds way fancier than it
really is but it is a scheduler and all
of these components are open source yeah
that is very good well we put a link to
the repo in the show notes there's one
more question that I wanted to ask but
I've been curious about it for quite a
long time I I assumed that there would
be a Travis somewhere in Travis CI what
why is Travis CI called
Travis so that story goes back to well
the first of all people tend to think
there's someone someone in our team is
named Travis yeah I was expecting I was
I was called Travis on multiple
occasions but it goes back to Bob the
Builder Wow yeah that's that's the
response it usually comes back from that
bob has a tractor and that tractors name
is Travis Wow okay I really did not
expect that we need we need a picture of
that tractor on the shownotes the story
around that is there in the in the early
stages
Travis see I used a tool which was
called Bob yep which was it's just a
simple Ruby script that was used to will
run builds
and so it was Bob and Travis just
working together there you go
this is Travis excellent no one else can
see that because we're on a podcast well
we'll put a picture of this it's it's
okay I didn't know I knew somehow but
but the Bob the Builder but now Travis I
also have to ask because I can't believe
Frances Kazon what languages do you use
the Travis intro okay so from the where
we used to be a very Ruby heavy shop and
like a lot of us come from the the Ruby
open-source community so the you know
the earliest version of Travis were
built a build around building Ruby and
at some point for a while they ran on
JRuby and production whoo I have a
really soft spot for JRuby yeah it's
been it's allowed us to scale up to in
interesting ways
nowadays most of our components are just
running on C Ruby and MRI because less
resource-intensive
and the build execution parts are the
part that you know creates instances and
runs the builds these are now mostly
written and go we have parts of our
infrastructure that are still running on
an old JRuby system but we're looking to
replace that with the go execution
excellent very cool what made you decide
to write stuff and go how did you end up
at that conclusion that's a question I
can't really answer about rate just
happened that was a team decisions right
yeah so just because go is amazing yeah
it's all yeah was amazing if people want
to try Travis CI out where can they go
where should they go what's the best way
of getting started uh well if you have
an open source project simply go to
Travis CI org and you know sign in with
your give it a github account get
started yeah it is very easy and he's
totally worth it if you have not tried
it
I agree well thank you so much for
taking the time to come into the Google
office half lunch and a little bit with
us my pleasure thank you for having me
I'm getting great thank you thank you so
much to Matthias for joining us today
having a great chat about continuous
integration continuous deployment and
also the interesting stuff that's going
on at Travis CI and the most interesting
part definitely the origin of Travis yes
yep I didn't know that so that was very
cool to learn that was really really
cool as well so let's have a chat about
that
question of the week yeah so the
question of the week I think that this
one was someone asked you this during an
event yeah so I was at an event and
someone was chatting to me about
building custom schedulers within
communities and how they could get
involved with that whole aspect of it at
the time I wasn't quite sure where to
send them so I ended up having to do
some research hmm so I basically hunted
around and I realized that kubernetes
has a series of what's called special
interest groups or sinks that basically
cover each different aspect of
kubernetes so there's one for scheduling
there's one for network there's one for
scalability this one for storage sets
etc they're really cool they've got
people who run them they have regular
meetings that happen they have slack
channels and dedicated specifically to
them so if it's something that you're
like oh I really want to get involved
with how kubernetes order scales for
example or you know I really want to dig
into this side of the open source
project it's a really easy way to find
the right pathway and the right people
to talk to and the Google group to get
on I'll have a link in the show notes
there's just a whole page with mark down
inside github that lists all of these so
that you can get involved really really
easily ya know they look they're very
interesting I really like that there's
even things like Federation which is a
very open very active topic yep I wonder
what people are talking about around in
there yeah so I think I actually think
it's a great way of running running the
community and getting people involved so
yeah very very cool excellent well
franceska thank you so much for coming
and joining me once more are you gonna
be anywhere particularly interesting in
the next few weeks so by the time this
comes out I will be in Denver Colorado
and I will have finished already my talk
at gopher con and I will be a happy
gopher I'm sure will have been excellent
I'm sure I'm sure well what could go
wrong but yeah I'll be I'll be still
hanging out a gopher con so you by any
chance you were a listener and you're a
gopher con or any where in Denver let me
know awesome I think for me coming up I
may have some other events come up
beforehand we'll see but in August I
will definitely be at PAX dev in some
capacity so if you want to talk about
cloud
Gaming just hunt me down or find me on
Twitter I will be at that event so super
excited for that great sounds good
what do you say maybe since we have not
done it in a while we love it we remind
people how to get in touch with us
sounds good cool so we are on Twitter
yes at GCP podcast we are on Google Plus
at plus GCP podcast we are on reddit /
our /gc - podcast ah we have a webpage
at cloud.google.com slash podcast or
just blog has become the same thing we
also have an email at hello at GCP
podcast and finally we also have a
channel in the group club platform slack
community yes the hashed podcast Channel
there you go so yeah many ways to
contact us so no excuse if you have a
question or any kind of critique you
just want to say hi how are we doing
yeah feel free absolutely waiting for
your messages wonderful alright well yet
again thank you so much for joining me
this week France ask thank you mark and
see you all next week